in the early days of Android we made the
first SDK available as a preview to
developers the vibrant developer
ecosystem and open platform have been
important keys to our success which is
why I'm excited that were once again
giving developers a very early preview
of some of what's in store in the
upcoming version of Android Android P
your early feedback is crucial to our
efforts to push the boundaries of mobile
development in Android P jobscheduler
has been improved to let it better
handle network related jobs jobs can now
declare their estimated data size signal
prefetching and specify detailed network
requirements for example when a network
was reported by the carrier is being
congested job scheduler might defer
large Network requests while it can take
advantage of surplus metered capacity to
run a prefetch job that returns content
that will substantially improve the apps
user experience such as prefetching top
headlines Android P brings performance
and efficiency improvements to art
androids runtime we've expanded arts use
of execution profiles to optimize apps
and reduce the in-memory footprint of a
compiled app code art now uses profile
information for on device rewriting of
Dex files with reductions of up to 11%
across a range of popular apps these
correlate closely with reductions in
system Dex memory usage and faster
startup times Kotlin is seeing massive
growth in the developer community we
have heard so much Kotlin love from
developers and we are deepening our
Kotlin investments in P you'll see the
first results of our platform work with
new optimizations in art out - written
with Kotlin will run faster on P than on
previous versions of Android we're
continuing to work with JetBrains to
optimize the Kotlin compiler and we're
also improving our brand new dax-ur to
make sure generated code from Kotlin can
run as fast as possible also make sure
to check out our ongoing preview of
android KTX which is a set of extensions
designed to make android Kotlin
development even more concise and
pleasant Android introduces an easier
way to decode images to either bitmaps
or drawables with image decoder which
replaces bitmap factory image decoder
election create a bitmap or drawable
from a byte buffer file or URI it offers
several advantages over bitmap factory
including support for exact scaling
single step decoding to hardware memory
support for post-processing
to code and decoding of animated images
image decoder allows you to supply a
callback that is called after the header
is decoded where you can alter the
output rather than having decode to head
her twice decode drawable allows you to
create drawables directly the encoded
image is an animated gif or web P the
drawable will be an instance of the new
animated image drawable to help deliver
the highest quality viewing experience
Android P adds built-in support for HDR
vp9 profile - enabling the delivery of
HDR enabled movies we also added support
for a substantially improved image
compression with hav C compressed a gif
images which means smaller downloads and
less on device storage and we're in the
process of enhancing and refactoring the
media API s so stay tuned you can access
streams simultaneously from devices that
have logical cameras consisting of
multiple physical devices such as dual
front or dual rear cameras enabling new
app possibilities other improvements in
camera include new session parameters to
reduce delays during initial capture and
surface sharing reducing the need for
camera clients to stop and start camera
streaming
we've also added api's for display based
flash support and access to OS
timestamps to allow apps to perform
image stabilization or use this data for
special effects Android P as an API for
the I Triple E 8o 2.11 MC Wi-Fi protocol
also known as Wi-Fi round-trip time RT t
to let you take advantage of indoor
positioning in your apps Android P
devices with hardware support can use RT
t you measure the distance to a nearby
Wi-Fi access point that supports the
protocol the device doesn't need to
connect to the AP to use RT t and to
maintain privacy only the phone is able
to determine the distance by measuring
distances to three or more access points
apps can calculate the position with an
accuracy of one to two meters Android P
as an implementation of the global
platform Open Mobile API to Android on
supported devices apps can use o map e
to access NFC secure elements on Android
devices to enable smart card payments
and other secure services the neural
networks API was introduced in Android
81 to provide support for accelerated on
device machine learning in
we're expanding and approving the API
adding support for nine new ops on pixel
to the DP one build includes an
accelerated driver for quantized models
Android P is part of our longer-term
initiative to modernize the foundations
of the platform and the apps that run on
it we announced recently that Google
Play will require all app updates to at
least target Android Oreo
by November 2018 and require apps to the
NDK library to provide 64-bit support in
2019 in line with these changes and
repeat will warn users with the dialog
when they install an app that targets an
Android platform earlier than Android
4.2 and future versions will continue to
increment that limit every Android
developer should start planning to
migrate to target at least API 26 now
and we built the checklist of resources
to help and support this effort we're
always looking for ways to improve the
user and developer experience in this
spirit we're working to ensure that apps
don't use non SDK interfaces since doing
so risks crashes for users and emergency
rollouts for developers in Android n we
restricted the set of symbols at NDK
code could use and with Android P or
further increasing stability by
expanding these restrictions to cover
the SDK interfaces as well in the
preview you'll see a warning when you
use a non SDK interface that we plan to
restrict if you feel that you'll need
the SDK API expanded to stop using non
SDK ones please let us know as soon as
you can via our bug tracker in Android P
were providing a standard system dialog
to prompt the user to touch the
fingerprint sensor managing text and
placement as appropriate for the device
apps can trigger the system fingerprint
dialog using a new fingerprint dialog
API we recommend switching to the new
system dialog as soon as possible as the
previous API may not be compatible with
new devices as part of a larger effort
to move all network traffic away from
clear text unencrypted HTTP to TLS we're
also changing the defaults or network
security configuration to block all
clear text traffic an Android P and
higher after the network security
configuration must make connections over
TLS unless they explicitly opt in to
clear text for specific domains to
better ensure user privacy Android P
restricts all
access to microphones cameras and
sensors from idle apps when an app is
idle the mic will report empty audio and
the sensors will stop reporting events
while camera is used by the app will be
disconnected and generate airs if the
app tries to use them
Android P gives the user control of our
access to the building identifier by
putting it under the read phone state
permission direct access to this
identifier has been deprecated since
Android a doe Android P adds platform
support for edge to edge displays with
cutouts the status bar will adapt its
height automatically asked with critical
immersive content can use a new platform
API in window in sets to get the cutout
balance and a new API in the window
manager layout params to request layout
in the cutout area the updated messaging
style notification makes it easier to
display notifications involving people
or groups of people it provides a
standardized way to handle images and
handle suggested replies give your users
a seamless transition to Android P just
download a device or emulator system
image install your app and test the
Android P Developer Preview includes an
updated SDK with system images for
testing on the official Android emulator
and on pixel pixel XL pixel to and pixel
to XL devices speaking of the emulator
it's a great place to test or develop on
Android P it's incredibly fast and
convenient to use and you can even model
long screens and screens with the
display cut out for cameras and sensors
after you've tested handle any P
behavior changes make any necessary
updates and publish to Google Play
without changing the platform target
then change your apps targeting to P and
run it with the full Android P
experience explore the many new features
in api's you can take advantage of in
your app take a look at the API differ
port along with the Android P API
reference you can start building with P
by downloading the developer preview SDK
and tools in Android studio we're also
releasing an album version of the 28000
support library for you to try check out
the release notes for complete details
we plan to update the preview system
images and SDK regularly this initial
release is for developers only and not
intended for daily or consumer use so
we're making it available by manual
download and flash only as we get closer
to a final product we'll be inviting
consumers to try it out as well and
we'll open up enroll
sir Android beta at that time stay tuned
for details but for now please note that
Android beta is not currently available
for Android P as always your feedback is
critical so please let us know what you
think the sooner we hear from you the
more of your feedback we can integrate
look in the video description for
details on how to report issues and stay
tuned this is just our first preview
after all the Android pee story is just
beginning
[Music]